I'm so confident that you guys get
mathematical induction as an overall
process that I am NOT going to tell you
a single thing to write down for the
first two and a half steps I'm going to
get you guys to tell me everything so I
know nothing about mathematical
induction how would you like me to begin
come on all right you can give me a
first step okay
so rather than use the word prove by the
way I'm going to use the word so I don't
know nothing about my very good lecture
I'm gonna use the word test because I'm
actually doing something different right
I'm checking I look really proving
anything so I'm just gonna test that now
what was the value that we started with
really Wow guys we got one two three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 12
13 14 15 characters into the question
and then we stopped reading we can read
more than 15 characters can't we first
proper value is going to be an equals
eight okay now what we tried me to do we
could do either you said left first
let's just go with it because as you
know like we got a test both sides
eventually anyway we know what the
left-hand side looks like it's gonna be
you rank you tell me you can see it on
the board it's gonna be can you tell me
what to write at least you know the
thumb of the answer is thank you very
much if you know your powers are -
really well then you'll know this is 256
so if you not that's okay you've got a
calculator there for that reason there's
the left hand side I guess I'll do the
right hand side now what are we gonna
write 3 times 8 squared that's three
times 64 which lasts I check was a
hundred and ninety-two
okay is the inequality true for N equals
eight it is true there's a left there's
the right therefore what I want is good
so I've got my first value happy times
okay what was the second step I've
tested now I'm going to make an
assumption what is my assumption again
for some arbitrary value okay but don't
forget K is not just any number K is the
same kind of number that any is right so
I write that all down like so this
doesn't take too much thought I'm just
gonna replace all my ends with k's
wonderful what am i try proof for don't
you can help me out
thank you very much and you're doing so
well why don't you tell me what actually
I'm going to write
[Music]
very good
don't forget just like before you're
putting K plus 1 into there the whole
thing is being squared don't cheat on
your brackets you really need them ok
that's what I need okay that's what I'm
after but I said to you before we can
aim for you know getting everything on
one side and then proving them that's
greater than zero that is one method of
proof and it's totally fine but there's
this other way and depending on the kind
of question you get sometimes one
strategy will be superior to another or
more efficient okay almost always you
can use either but I need you to be able
to use both because sometimes you can't
use either and there's really only one
path that will get you efficiently to
the question okay so this time what I'm
gonna do is I'm instead of getting
everything on one side I'm gonna start
with the Assumption my first line of
working is going to be this do you see
that there's the assumption right there
here comes my proof because the very
first theme that I used is the
assumption I'm just gonna write it as it
is and right away immediately I have to
say by assumption okay now
at this point I am now thinking right I
want to get towards here
you remember how in all like trick
identity and proofs by induction we've
seen before you've always got your eye
on the prize right so what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to work with this in
such a way as to get it to here right in
previous questions you've been working
with this thing to try and see where's
the assumption in there right you don't
need to do that anymore why not
why don't I need to have to look in this
thing to find where the assumption is
I've already used the assumption right
it's done the inductive hypothesis has
been assumed so I don't need to search
for it again it's been it's been
substituted in now I need to get to here
that's my goal okay